l'oeuvre du dragon a fait peau neuve la
dernière restauration datait des années
1990 la communauté d'agglomération et le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines inscrivent ses travaux dans une
politique globale de restauration de son
patrimoine
l'oeuvre a été replacé dans son lieu
d'origine il ya une quarantaine
d'oeuvres bon on peut pas tout faire en
même temps il fallait faire des choix
alors cette oeuvre là parce qu'elle
était vraiment en mauvais état le socle
sur lequel était posée était dans un
état pitoyable
donc il fallait il fallait la changer et
en même temps il y avait déjà cette idée
de éventuellement la faire gagner cet
emplacement ici du maïdo seule la
restauration a coûté environ 12000 euros
les travaux du dragon ont eu lieu
pendant le confinement et ont duré deux
semaines
les difficultés enlever les couches de
vernis teintées et les traces de
vandalisme sur l'oeuvre de 500 kg
c'était une intervention qui était
intéressante puisqu'il y avait quand
même des couches de surface auquel on
n'était pas habitué assez agréable
puisque dans le contexte du confinement
on a eu le temps de consacrer tout le
temps qu'il fallait à la réflexion et à
l'identification des problématiques
après c'est une restauration qui est
quand même assez classique en fait dans
les opérations on est souvent sur des
bronzes comme ça sur des opérations de
nettoyage cirage retouches dans le
courant de l'année prochaine une
deuxième phase de restauration du mile
des sols est prévu notamment concernant
les oeuvres
le letton et la table des géants